welcome to this video playing a
grandmaster kabhi yaad kbj bong Revilla
you are from the Philippines okay yeah I
haven't played him before I mean I
probably have played him before but not
here on video okay the slide I had tried
a couple of times recently and let's see
what we get is playing with e6 so we get
a position with this which is served
quite similar to the Queens gambit the
regular Queensgate Edworthy six um okay
hmm it seems that i probably made a
mistake in the move water here yeah he's
got quite a bit 94 he's got them some
some play now here hmm well that's not
good keep any simplify matters here and
I probably III was was a bad move or
what I need to play Knight c3 first two
to prevent the check hmm okay
okay i think i can keep the bishop for
the moma Bishop before I still have
whoopsie one so I'm not in a huge
trouble with this with this pin
yeah this kind of maneuver not a five a
queen 85 90 form so a camel in all kinds
of Queens gambit situations and you need
to be quite quite cautious as you can
easily lose material if uh if you are
somewhat yeah if you if he makes a
mistake down okay mmm I guess he wants
to play Knight c3 bc 94 again and Bishop
d3 this may be Bishop a no Bishop f5 I
can take be 70 okay so maybe I should
just do that not think about it too long
if I get castled um I'm okay anyway yeah
this this kind of operation is also a
bit time-consuming phone to black so um
it's um it's um sometimes not really
working out well for him and no Bishop
f5 probably
and maybe a three here Bishop takes beat
eggs I'm not sure he's got a good
discovered move
yeah bishops III bc 3 I don't really see
a great night movie night c5 I can take
on c5 Bishop d3 and Queen B 7 at least
this check and not sure night f2 is
really pointless i can take f5 the night
on edge one will be be trapped and yeah
where is he going this also be seven
just hanging so he can he can play oh
that sound that's surprising really
isn't this just weakening the position a
lot night 95 maybe
yeah and here this even f3 amongst
others i mean i can also take a take b5
even that is interesting probably not
convincing but interesting it is okay
and now i can take and play follow him
at least I can try to you for
immediately
ok now if you're kidding i can play g4
ok not sure I really you know only have
one minute something left so on I
shouldn't spend them an extraordinary
amount of time yeah if he know takes I
have some play against c6 Quincy seven
runs into discovered discovered attacks
and other Queen position some yeah he
can do that but I have a forward list
okay so three nice looking position the
only problem is of course my king king
of ulnar ball at least them it can be a
problem okay King f2 maybe not quite
sure where to put it okay we both don't
you have much time left what's my plan
maybe ok one rupee Cedric 187 trying to
double on the on the 7th he really does
not have anything active going on maybe
you can claim somehow against my king
i'm not quite sure how but
okay twenty-six year what is because I
want to see your response now just
retreating I mean 96 I can take n play
Bishop c7 Edwin at least the exchange
yeah creepy a 27 yeah I can just play
Bishop c7 here yeah that's true but I
have this Muslim gained it winning the
c6 bowl ok I can go to g 3n so I'm not
check in some big trouble ahem night g
691 a bee
mmm what's easiest maybe maybe this one
black one yeah he can play lie to h4 but
this is just a check on g2 not not much
more yeah very complicated opening where
I probably i don't know maybe III is
really not precise allowing this Queen a
fight maybe it is better ready to start
with this to to not have this check to
to play against yeah Chad it's a bit
tricky now I don't think I can I can do
something like that this this is quickly
quickly getting problematic there's also
a move like g5 at the position maybe
even immediately the idea being that
this is a double attack now that's very
interesting so i think i think i played
this right i should take him simplifying
matters now of course he can take here
and gain the bishop pair there should be
quite okay for black you will get a
temple back with Bishop e7 okay and this
looks normal yeah rooks you one no III
jack yeah the computer wants to play
Knight c5 interesting I already thought
that this should be quite good him but
yeah the computer is totally unimpressed
it wants to play long castles here
probably you can and then the night c5
is what black should do in this this is
just leading to a very good position
Queen before it's also good that always
should should keep some sort of
advantage a form yeah this is quite
quite similar to what the computer wants
to play always keeping an edge young
here 26 is just good for what yeah so
very straightforward when he should play
this here you should play this this 95
move it seems going for long castles
should be okay okay thanks for watching